-Amid a torrent
of national outrage
and widespread protests
over the Supreme Court's
grotesque decision
to shred abortion rights,
Republicans are shamelessly
claiming that it's Democrats
who are staging riots
by peacefully protesting.
And, on top of that,
they're trying to gaslight
everybody into thinking
nothing has been banned
as a result of this decision.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Tens of thousands
of outraged Americans poured
into the streets
over the weekend
to channel their grief
and indignation
over the fact that the right
to bodily autonomy
of women and pregnant people
was incinerated
by a corrupt gang
of unaccountable,
right-wing theocrats
who definitely think
"The Scarlet Letter"
was a comedy, including --
[ Laughter ]
the racist neighbor
who calls the cops
when your leaves blow
on his lawn,
Mike Pence's son...
or dad...
[ Laughter ]
...and the sniveling rich kid
who buys the town rec center
and bulldozes it
to build a luxury condo.
[ As Kavanaugh ]
You can hold all the
fundraisers you want!
You'll never
raise enough money
to save your precious
indoor pool!
[ Laughter ]
Poll after poll after poll
has shown that a large majority
of Americans
are opposed to overturning Roe,
and that majority showed up
in large numbers
over the weekend in a series
of nationwide protests.
-The decision sent tens
of thousands of people
into the streets
this weekend to protest.
-There were nonstop
demonstrations over the weekend
and they're expected
to continue.
-All day long, the crowds have
been steadily building here
at Washington Square Park.
Across the nation,
at least 100 demonstrations
are planned in the coming days.
-I'm most worried
about what comes next
because Roe v Wade
was a precedent
for Obergefell v Hodges,
Loving v Virginia,
Irving v Texas --
gay marriage,
interracial marriage,
and privacy in the bedroom.
And those, as Clarence Thomas
came out yesterday,
they're going to be falling
like dominoes.
-Yeah, that's right.
And let me just note,
for a moment, the difference
between the protesters
at a pro-abortion rights rally,
who are deeply familiar
with the jurisprudence
and have read the text
of Clarence Thomas's
concurring opinion
and, say, the dinguses
who showed up
to the Capitol on January 6th,
hopped up on forwarded emails
and Reddit threads,
to jack lecterns
and dress like werewolves
from a crappy role playing game
that came out on Sega Genesis
in 1994.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, yeah, I made sure
to call it a lectern, this time,
because a bunch of jackals
in our YouTube comments section
[ Laughter ]
lost their [bleep] every time
I called it a podium,
because I guess that's
the real crime from January 6th.
[ Laughter ]
And let me just say,
as a general rule, that --
and this is just me speaking --
it feels like a bad sign
when we have to know
this many names
of Supreme Court cases.
I open Twitter.
I see some new,
horrifying case trending, like
New York State Rifle & Pistol
Association v Bruen,
in which the court
magically invented
a constitutional right
to concealed carry;
or Carson v Makin,
in which the court forced
local governments
to fund religious schools;
or Wally v Spell Check,
in which the court found
that our cue card guy, Wally,
is not required to double-check
the spelling on the cue cards.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It -- It looks right
to me, Seth.
-It's wrong
and you know it's wrong.
-Sorry.
Take it up with the court.
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh!
This is, suffice it to say,
a radical court just mowing down
precedents they don't like
and selectively reading
whatever they want
in the Constitution
to further their brazen,
ideological agenda.
They literally just pick
and choose the clauses they like
and ignore the ones they don't.
Like the one that prohibits
the government
from respecting
an establishment of religion
or the one that says guns are
for a well-regulated militia
or the one that says,
"Oh, no, citizen shall ever be
denied the right
to use a teleprompter."
Oh, interesting. Did you ever
notice that one, Wally?
-Uh, um, uh --
Expand the court!
-Wally!
[ Laughter ]
So, Americans are
understandably outraged
that a rogue court just decided,
on a whim,
to shred abortion rights,
purely because it could,
and went even further,
essentially announcing,
through Thomas's concurrence,
that it would target
contraception,
marriage equality,
and privacy next.
And, yet, the shameless weirdos
on the right,
instead of confronting
the reality
for millions of Americans
who just lost
a fundamental
constitutional right,
putting their health at risk
and relegating them
to second-class status,
chose, absurdly, to accuse
proabortion activists
of staging riots.
-When you look at the Democrats,
if they do not get their way,
what do they do?
They go out and they riot.
-The left doesn't know
how absurd they look.
They're fighting, they're
having these hissy fits.
Every time they don't like
something, they hit the streets.
They become violent.
-Protests, vandalism,
erupting across the country,
from Portland
to Washington, D.C.
immediately following
the Supreme Court's abortion
ruling Friday.
-I don't think anything's going
to calm down the far left.
They're always looking
for something
to scream about
and burn buildings over.
-Whenever a news story happens
that Fox knows is bad
for Republicans politically,
like overturning
an overwhelmingly popular
constitutional right,
Fox tries to pivot
by convincing your grandparents
that antifa is currently
outside their house, right now,
[ Laughter ]
threatening to steal
their flagstones
and take their
lawn gnomes hostage.
[ Laughter ]
"Hello, 911?
There's a socialist
outside my house,
attacking my mailbox.
Yes, I know he's a liberal
because he's wearing
short shorts."
[ Laughter ]
They love to do this childish
thing where they accuse the left
of doing the thing
they actually did.
Like they're the ones
who fomented a violent coup
to overthrow the government.
Today, we literally found out,
from shocking testimony,
that Trump wanted his supporters
to march to the Capitol armed
and said security should let
them through with weapons.
But if someone holds up a sign
that says, "My body, my choice,"
right-wingers lose
their [bleep].
"These liberal protesters just
march wherever they want!
At least, when we tried
to hang Mike Pence,
we were courteous enough to give
him a five-minute warning,
by chanting, 'Hang Mike Pence!'
[ Laughter ]
We gave him a head start!"
And, when they're not lying
and calling the left violent,
they're lying and calling
the left hysterical
because, again, they're aware
that this could be bad
for them politically,
so, they're trying
to have it both ways.
They want to celebrate
the victory,
while also gaslighting everyone
into thinking nothing
has actually been banned.
-The Supreme Court didn't
outlaw it.
What they did was move it back
to the states.
-What is so interesting to me --
calls coming into our office,
when they would say,
"Oh, we don't want
a ban on abortion,"
we would say, "Well, it's not."
-This is not a ban on abortions
across the country.
This puts this back
in the hands of the people.
-The liberals are
misstating this.
Abortion is not banned
in all states.
-I don't think we can
emphasize enough --
abortion is not illegal.
It's not been outlawed.
-If you watch some of these
tweets and you see some
of this reporting, you think
abortion's been banned,
nothing's been banned.
-Nothing's been banned?
Are you insane?
This is the [bleep]
Jedi mind trick I've ever seen.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, with a Jedi
mind trick,
you usually need
to be able to project calm,
and Hannity is incapable
of that.
[ As Hannity ]
These are not the droids
you're looking for!
[ Laughter ]
They are Hunter Biden's droids.
Rudy Giuliani got them
at a junk market
from Jar Jar Binks.
Rudy joins us now.
[ As Giuliani ]
Sean, yousa not gonna believe
what meesa gonna tell you.
[ Laughter ]
Thirteen states
have trigger laws,
that either made abortion
instantly illegal,
as soon as the decision
was handed down,
or will make it illegal
very soon.
And there are several more
states that are likely to join,
meaning all or most abortions
could soon be illegal
or severely restricted
in at least 20 states,
if not more.
This ruling was not theoretical.
It put millions of women
and people
who can become pregnant
in jeopardy immediately.
These guys don't issue
hypothetical rulings.
It's a rogue court hell-bent
on remaking America
as an authoritarian,
right-wing theocracy.
Conservatives have shattered
the court
and shredded whatever remaining
legitimacy it may have had.
This is an institution
that counts, among its members,
two who have been credibly
accused of sexual misconduct;
several who lied to Congress
to get the gig,
in the first place;
at least one
whose seat was stolen;
another whose family made money
from right-wing groups
and didn't report it,
and who ruled on cases
implicating his spouse,
who was directly involved
in a coup
to overthrow
the United States government;
and another who,
during his confirmation hearing,
claimed there was a shadowy plot
to destroy him
orchestrated by,
among other people,
the Clintons.
-This whole two-week effort
has been a calculated
and orchestrated political hit,
fueled with apparent
pent-up anger
about President Trump
and the 2016 election,
fear that has been
unfairly stoked
about my judicial record,
revenge on behalf
of the Clintons.
-Remember that?
Talk about hysterical.
[ Laughter ]
Are we all just supposed
to go back to pretending
this guy could be
a fair-minded judge
who puts partisan
politics aside,
after he essentially accused
Hillary Clinton
of sneaking into his closet
and writing,
"Beers with PJ and Squi"
on his high school calendar.
[ Laughter ]
Not to mention the fact that
a majority of the conservative
justices on the court
have been appointed
by Republican presidents
who lost the popular vote,
including three by Trump,
who lost twice,
by a combined 10 million votes.
One of his appointees
even posed with him
on the White House balcony
for a political photo op
eight days before the election,
like they were ushering in
the 75th Annual Hunger Games.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] May the odds be
ever in your favor.
We love the Hunger Games,
don't we, folks?
[ Laughter and applause ]
We love. Everybody loves --
Everybody loves
Katniss Everdeen,
but for my money,
the king of the Hunger Games?
Joey Chestnut.
Joey Chestnut --
[ Laughter ]
when it comes
to the Hunger Games,
you can't beat Joey.
I met him once at Coney Island,
[ Laughter ]
the great Joey Chestnut.
He walked up to me.
I'll never forget.
Tears in his eyes.
He walked up to me.
I'll never forget what he said.
He said -- [ Mumbling ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
The Supreme Court
has been revealed as a corrupt
and anti-democratic institution
whose conservative majority
has shredded
whatever legitimacy
it may have had
by dismantling a widely popular
constitutional right
to bodily autonomy,
purely because it could.
It's a rogue court that just
cherry-picks the precedents
and the parts
of the Constitution they like
and discards
the ones they don't.
That's it. Their opinions aren't
serious legal documents.
They're just wordy, judicial...
-Hissy fits.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.